as far as my eyes go I feel like people
don't really pay them any mind I've
never gotten any compliments on my eyes
I always feel invisible with my blue
eyes and I feel like really clear
looking I totally wanted to try blue
eyes weighing with color is always cool
growing up in the South like having like
skin light eyes is very celebrated so
growing up I always wanted to have like
light eyes I'm the only one in my family
that has blue eyes I have six siblings I
always wanted brown eyes just because
everybody else in my family has them
today what we're going to do is change
the eye color of three different
patients
now the fitting of contact lenses
whether they be just purely for cosmetic
purposes or for the correction of vision
it's still a medical device and one
needs to be examined by an eye doctor to
be fit appropriately I'm going to be
trying blue eyes and maybe trying out
green eyes I'm gonna be trying brown
eyes okay we've got both lenses in now
check it out whoa oh my jeans well it
feels like I put someone's eye ball into
my head Oh am i I expected to hate this
I actually kind of love it I feel like
the reaction is gonna be positive
because it's such a cool thing to change
I am a little bit nervous about wearing
colored contacts because I'm worried
that people will think that I don't
think that my own brown eyes as they are
are beautiful enough I assume people
will notice that something on my face is
darker the guy who helped me put the
lenses in was like you look like a
completely different person I do look
like the rest of my family feel like
just augmenting one part of my body has
made me feel like more beautiful and I
think I'm gonna become
like even now I'm like hey girl I look
less like a cyborg today and more like a
cat so I just stood him in for the
second time I feel like I've acclimated
to them and they just look like my
normal eyes I kind of hurt I don't
understand how people do this every
morning I feel like a lot bolder I like
being another person I feel like people
look at me different whoa you're looking
demon I don't know what my boyfriend
will feel like will he dumped me I don't
know we'll see oh I'm very used to you
with the blue eyes I don't know they're
like piercing saying some people
sometimes I get used to it but yeah I
totally dig it you look like a mutant
from x-men they're entrancing I'm
entranced I think it's gonna be weird
for my boyfriend this is the trick do
you notice something different my eyes
uh-huh yeah your eyes are different ah
are they blue yeah oh my gosh one of the
things I've noticed about wearing them
is I've always wondering if people are
gonna notice they kind of fit
they're like brighter like feel like
hits you with a face gotcha going in the
trash bye
no more contacts I enjoyed the
experience a lot after seeing what I
would look like but it was a lot of
torture to get there I was shocked when
I put them in that I actually liked them
I was apprehensive because having come
into myself and really like celebrated
and loving myself I was afraid society
would think that I was like trying to
hide my like African heritage it totally
made my dreams come true do I look like
a part of my family now I think they're
like finally one of the most powerful
lessons I've learned in life is loving
your body as it is as it changes as it
grows like loving it for what it is and
once I die the mortician will be like oh
this is weird like this 90 year old
woman has contacts and